bonsoir avec six poulains les jo vont
rouvrir avant vous précipiter dessus
vous restez avec nous quelques minutes
aujourd'hui près de 4 millions de
français vaccinés vont perdre leur pass
vaccinale faute de rappel il ya eu un
petit point de communication du
gouvernement oui c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire je crois que plus personne
ne comprend ces mesures à la fois une
injection qui vaut une infection une
affection qui vaut une injection le 15
février c'était dans la tête de personne
en réalité les gens n'ont pas vu cette
date arriver donc ils n'ont pas anticipé
la troisième dose ou la dose puisqu'il
faut une dose peu importe le nombre
d'infections et puis on ne sait plus
finalement on parle de mesure levée en
réalité non les mesures sont toujours là
on ne comprend pas le pass vaccinale
commence à peser très lourd et puis je
voudrais ce soir penser à tous ceux qui
ont perdu leur travail qui ont été
soumis à cette obligation vaccinale les
soignants les ambulanciers les pompiers
qui eux sont sans emploi depuis des mois
et puis ces millions de français qui
sont désactivés d'un jour à l'autre
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la dose qu'il
faut alors que les études commencent à
arriver pour dire avec au micron la
troisième dose ne sert quasiment à rien
pour les moins de 60 ans enfin en terme
de bénéfice risque du moins et puis je
ne vois pas comment le gouvernement peut
continuer avec ce pass vaccinale sachant
que ckoi 45% de la population qui n'a
pas la troisième dose donc entre les
infections peut-être qu'on va arriver à
se raccrocher aux branches mais c'est
plus de 10 millions de français voire
beaucoup plus qui aujourd'hui risquent
de ne pas avoir de passes travail à
quelques grogne quand même parmi eux des
sénateurs nerfs qui appelle à la levée
immédiate du pass vaccinale est ce que
c'est possible c'est tout à fait
possible compte tenu aujourd'hui des
chiffres de la drees et puis il n'y a
pas d'embouteillage dans les hôpitaux
contrairement à ce que dit gabriel
atteint dans un cas classique mais le
coc vide n'est plus ce qu'il a été les
pics qu'on a connu auparavant ce qu'on
voit c'est que c'est devenu un objet
politique regardez au canada ce qui
s'est passé avec les convois la liberté
on n'a plus le droit de dire qu'il faut
lever le passé pourtant la lutte a payé
puisque le québec val le passe en france
c'est pareil pourquoi les sénateurs et
leers insee tribune et on peut les
remercier c'est parce que emmanuel
macron utiliser la levée du pass comme
un outil politique dans sa campagne pour
dire qu'il a vaincu locaux vides alors
qu'il n'en est rien aujourd'hui on sait
que les commandes de vaccins s'arrête
mais elles reprennent en mai donc en
fait c'est simplement un moratoire le
temps de la campagne pour faire croire
que le comider derrière nous grâce à
emmanuel macron avec en plus cette levée
du pass vaccinale qui est un pasa trou
puisque vacciner on peut contaminer donc
il ya nécessité de lever le pass dès à
présent on voit d'ailleurs c'est ce qui
se passe en grande-bretagne aux pays-bas
au danemark où tout est levée pourquoi
vouloir continuer absolument en france
alors que en réalité aucune mesure n'a
jusqu'à présent juguler l'épidémie de
quid si ce n'est au micron qui permet à
tous finalement d'avoir locaux vides
sans aller forcément en réanimation pour
autant les convois de la liberté ont
tous été mis en échec pour l'instant en
france quelles suites possibles la suite
possible ça va être la désobéissance je
pense ou le refus de continuer à jouer
au jeu du pass à savoir si c'est un
numéro impair où percent il faut une
troisième une quatrième dose on l'a déjà
vu la fatigue des français par rapport à
la troisième dose beaucoup ont traîné
des pieds pour y aller très peu
finalement 45% je le disais donc ce qui
reste vu la la la le dispositif policier
qui a été mis en place contre les
convois de la liberté à paris mais aussi
à bruxelles et puis on voit la faible
mobilisation a malheureusement on peut
le regretter mais se battre pour les
libertés finalement c'est pas quelque
chose qui intéresse et qui agrège donc
comment continuer et puis si on continue
si on regarde ces convois de la liberté
le problème c'est que au canada
maintenant justin trudeau n'a pas honte
de demander à avoir des sanctions
financières sur les gens qui ont
supporté financièrement ces convois de
la liberté en disant que voilà les
banques vont pouvoir geler les avoirs
des gens qui ont donné à la cagnotte et
c'est donc ce sera je pense un retour à
la vie normale sans passe pour une
majorité de français qui vont arrêter de
jouer à ce jeu qu'on n'arrive plus à
comprendre en fait les règles changent
trop souvent et puis
maintenant je crois que tout le monde a
envie de tourner la page qu'ovide même
si il est toujours avec nous merci avec
six poulains pour votre édito est pour